Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
video all about them canceling a bunch of the
cw arrowverse shows what's going on with dc's
larger plan for all of its content like people
are wondering shows are getting canceled is this
the end of the dc tv universe not quite what you
think but we have seen a version of this happen
before all the marvel fans out there just a couple
years ago saw the exact same thing happen to them
dc and warner brothers just had this big merger
with discovery they hyped all these huge changes
for the future of dc movies and dc tv shows just
in general like they even say that they're hiring
themselves a version of kevin feige as if kevin
feige himself has turned into a verb people
saying they're going to kevin feige the dc tv
universe somebody's going to control everything
and tell them what's going to get made what's
not going to get made as nice as it sounds it's
not quite as crazy as you expect so i'll explain
everything if you are new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything i will be doing
weekly videos for all the big budget dc hbo shows
that will be coming in the next year and they are
in the middle of making really big budget dc shows
like batman hbo shows green lantern hbo shows
even a peacemaker season two so don't worry you're
late you don't another fish i'm so sick of that
rumor it's not a rumor so this is probably a good
place to start you've probably seen in your fees
this past week that dc and cw canceled batwoman
and legends of tomorrow it's really just the tip
of the iceberg there's been talk about them
canceling the flash tv show after a shorter
than normal season nine next year like there
was a big deal about grant gustin negotiating
to be in less episodes of the flash the same way
that stephen amell did a final season of arrow but
the season itself was super short and was mostly a
sort of wrap up in crisis on infinite earth's kind
of season like if they had not been doing crisis
on infinite earth that year they probably would
have not done that final season of arrow like
green arrow no not like green arrow that dude goes
with brony conventions dressed in the back half
of twilight sparkle with a four-inch wide butthole
drilled in the costume no i actually heard that's
true about green arrow but that's the first thing
he said that's real an aquaman fish well yeah
obviously some of you are probably like wait a
minute they were still making new episodes of the
flash tv show there was still a batwoman show they
were still making legends of tomorrow what's going
on like you completely moved on to other forms of
entertainment since then there are really two big
reasons why the dc tv universe on the cw is sort
of spinning down coming to its natural end as you
used to know it most of it is getting cancelled
ending in some way and some of it is just getting
shuffled to a different platform you sort of have
to think of the peak of the classic dc tv universe
on the cw is being crisis on infinite earth like
that was meant to be the big culminating event the
thing that you never thought that they would be
able to do that they tried to pull off doing they
ended aero some of the shows continued after that
but it sort of reduced capacity and they said that
they weren't really doing giant huge crossovers
like that anymore like they weren't going to top
crisis on infinite earth so like we're not even
going to try so that's why you kind of have to
look at that as sort of the peak of dc tv universe
then they developed a superman and lois show
and they've kind of put that off by itself
even though technically it's meant to be connected
to the other dc tv shows they try to be really
careful about not referencing and not having a
bunch of crossovers with a ton of other shows
there's like a little bit of referencing the other
stuff but not really not like they used to have
a bunch of crossovers all the time they did just
announce that they're developing a diggle tv show
that's based on the justice league it's called
justice u with a bunch of lesser characters that
most of you probably never heard of and some
ones that they're creating brand new for the
tv show like we're not allowed to use a bunch of
big comic book characters so we're gonna create
some new ones for the show they're just making a
pilot for that they haven't picked it up to series
so the cw could wind up canceling that too there
is that naomi tv show that the cw has but they've
already confirmed that that said on a separate
earth that might get a season two but they haven't
said anything about it yet like they've gone way
past the time where they would normally announce
big renewals for next season so it's not looking
good for the dc tv universe as you used to know it
on the cw so one of the main reasons why they're
canceling some of this stuff is because it is so
long in the tooth like it's reached it's natural
end so it is time for a lot of it to end anyway
but the new owners of warner brothers discovery
this big combined company that they just sold to
are planning this big disney plus style redesign
for the dc tv on hbo max you see batman doesn't
kill people because he's a he's a dark creature of
the night i just did videos for the peacemaker hbo
series that was a big spin off of the suicide
squad movie that was the first example of that
so i'll post links in the description one of
the biggest differences of that show is that
previously the hallmarks of the classic cw shows
were that they had super long episode runs like 20
plus episodes per season in relatively low budgets
per episode that only involved one movie actor
here and there like very brief crossover with the
movies that one time because a crisis on infinite
earth with ezra miller meeting grant gustin's
version of the flash the what the flash the flash
the flash it's complicated it was a great moment
but that was like the zenith of the cw tv shows
and now warner brothers has been planning their
own version of what marvel did with the mcu
on disney plus they've been planning it for
a couple years now like you probably heard
about some of these shows like the green lantern
show the batman shows a couple of years ago it
just taken warner brothers in dc this long to
actually make those shows there are currently
two new batman hbo shows starring the actors and
the characters from robert pattinson's new batman
movie with matt reeves there's the
penguin show with colin farrell
there's the new batman arkham show which will
feature most of the villains that are inside
arkham right now we got a teaser for that
during the robert pattinson batman movie
the scene at the end of the movie with the joker
and the version the riddler getting their versions
of origin stories was sort of a teaser for the
arkham hbo series there was even that big deleted
scene with batman versus the joker inside arkham
that's something that they would address during
an arkham hbo show so that's like the biggest
of the big you could possibly do previously
doing batman on tv was sort of a no-go like
there was this big thing with him not being
able to use batman as a character the way you
would want them to use batman as a character
on any of these cw shows they had to create this
weird backstory about why batman wasn't around
like he disappeared they eventually did a version
of hush on batwoman he was kind of a low budget
version of hush the reason that whole rule with
no batman on tv actually started with christopher
nolan way back when he started doing batman begins
like way back in the day he told warner brothers
when he started working on the dark knight trilogy
he said that he didn't want them introducing some
alternate low budget version of batman on tv while
he was trying to hype up his brand new redesigned
serious version of batman with christian bale
because remember this was happening after he was
trying to reinvigorate the batman franchise right
after batman and robin with the george clooney
nipples version of batman so the past 10-20 years
or so we just had dc tv shows dc tv characters
all over the place all kinds of different tv
networks different people making the shows lots
of different cooks in the kitchen so that's how
you wind up with so many different versions of
the character all over the place at the same time
then what happened recently is all the studios
started rolling out their streamy networks like
disney plus hbo max the whole goals for what the
marvel shows the dc shows were supposed to
do for each of them just completely changed
normally the whole reason why studios even make
television shows is to license them to other tv
channels around the world to make a ton of money
and they made a ton of money doing stuff like this
but when all them owned streaming networks
the real goal for them to make money is by
having people subscribe to their networks and you
can't do that if you have like a billion different
versions of characters coming from a bunch of
different places like you really need to have all
your content in one specific place like this is
the only place where you're gonna see these heroes
that's why a couple years ago when i did this
video about them canceling the marvel netflix
shows because of disney plus they finally
put kevin feige in charge of all the creative
content that they made in marvel studios people
the movie people started making all the shows
specifically for disney plus you started to
see the movie actors show up on the shows
like i'm in the middle of making moon knight
episodes right now even though he's a brand
new character for marvel you haven't seen him in
the movies yet he is meant to cross over with the
future marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 movies how
did you just do that i'm a really good lawyer
that's why they cancelled most of the marvel tv
shows that came before the old stuff like they
canceled agents of shield they cancelled the ghost
rider tv show that they were getting ready to make
so now dc is basically doing the same thing
with the cw shows so basically all the networks
now not just dc marvel 2 a bunch of the other
streamers are taking all their content and trying
to move it exclusively to their streaming
networks just to entice you to subscribe
part of the reason why they cancel the other dc
tv shows instead of also just moving them to hbo
max because they could theoretically do that
is because one it's complicated to do that for
the older shows just because of the way they set
up the contracts and the people who were making
the shows and for example when they created the
superman and lois show they kind of knew what was
going to be happening a couple years down the road
so they planned for that to happen but just for
superman of lois the other really big thing that
you probably saw recently is that warner brothers
is trying to sell the cw just outright like
they're trying to get rid of the entire network
and when that happens the person who buys the
network doesn't want a lot of these more expensive
shows that aren't bringing in as many brand new
viewers as the brand new shows are this meme
will be the thing that survives the entire dc
tv universe but just in general the future of
the dc tv universe as you know it is going to be
more like the dceu tv universe on hbo max it's
super connected to the dc eu movies they can use
whichever characters they want and all the actors
like on the disney plus shows will show up in
future movie projects eventually early some of the
actors will like i said all the marvel fans went
through a version of this just a couple years ago
same basic thing is happening now but with all the
dc tv stuff here we go again so i will do more dc
episode videos but it's going to be a while before
some of that stuff premieres if you have any
questions about what's going on just in general
in the dc universe just post them in the comments
below my non-spoilery doctor strange 2 video
will post tuesday morning and then i'll start
doing full post credit scene videos easter eggs
everything for the movie later in the week after
it actually comes out my moon knight finale video
will also post after they release it as well so
really big week coming up everyone click here
for my moon knight episode 6 finale trailer video
and click here for my brand new doctor strange
2 trailer video with a whole bunch of cameos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!